well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror peppa
carrera and the sum harry cole welcome
and good to see both of you plenty to
discuss as we'll see from the newspapers
so let's take a look
starting with the guardian which leads
on the gatherings at downing street
reporting that the
prime minister's aide invited more than
100 staff to a party during the first
lockdown
that's also on the front of the metro
with the headline downing it street
and the eye leads on the same story
saying the prime minister and his wife
are also said to have attended the event
to the front page of the times pressure
mounts for five days of isolation their
headline after health chiefs admitted
they had misunderstood guidance from the
united states when they opposed a change
to the current rules
the yorkshire post reports on curved 19
rates in the region surpassing those of
london
boss johnson is urging people to get
their booster jab after the number of
people attending appointments began
falling after christmas that is the lead
as you can see for the sun and the ft
says russia has threatened to walk away
from talks on ukraine accusing the west
of ignoring its demands for security
guarantees
so we are joined then by the political
editors of the delhi mirror and the sun
pepper creera and harry cole welcome to
both of you and the first story pippa
right up your street obviously as the
breaker of of previous stanley street
gatherings uh downing it street says the
metro
goodness yeah but this is this this is
yet another alleged gathering um at
number 10 during lockdown although i
like the stories which i revealed which
were about this um last year developed
christmas last year this is about a
gathering in may 2020 which was revealed
by dominic cummings the pm's former
closest aide and now it looks like
archenemy um on friday in a blog post
and when dominic cummings
claimed that this party had taken place
he said that there'd been an email trail
and lo and behold tonight itv news have
found that email which came from martin
reynolds who's the senior civil servant
in the pm's private office and it really
is quite damning it suggests that up to
we sent up to 100 staff apparently about
30 or 40 attended and there were long
trestle tables in the dining street
garden laden with picnic foods and he
suggested people should bring their own
booze now this was on may 20th which as
you'll remember was um still at a point
when people were banned from meeting up
uh with more than one other person
outside and not half an hour before that
party was due to kick off then the then
culture secretary of the or oliver
dowden rather um was addressing their
number 10 briefing and reminding people
that they had to follow
follow rules when it came to meeting up
outside it's really quite damaging for
the prime minister i think this because
it directly implicates him with multiple
witnesses suggested that he was at that
drinks do with his wife carrie
and um and then on top of all of that
the met police have said tonight that
they are going to
talk to the cabinet office about this as
you'll know they have been resisting
investigating so far claiming there's
not enough evidence despite these
multiple allegations of gatherings this
looks like it may finally admit their
threshold okay interesting harry your
thoughts
yeah i think it was david cameron who
once said that boris johnson's of greece
piglet that gets away with things that
other people other politicians just
don't but it does sort of feel like the
uh the waters are lapping pretty close
to the prime minister now tonight martin
reynolds is probably a man that most
people have never heard of until about a
week ago but there it is in black and
white it's always this little paper
trail that gets you and i think it is
pippa just said there i think it's very
notable that police have been quite
quick out the um quick out the door out
of the traps tonight to say they are
preemptively getting in touch with the
cabinet office um other other gatherings
or alleged gatherings and witness
reports have been ignored but it's quite
hard to ignore a paper trail and it
looks like
dom cummings has been trying and
for many many months since his sort of
unceremonious departure from from
downing street to exact his revenge on
the prime minister and it looks like
he's um he's scored quite a hit tonight
uh the eye bring your own booze to some
people that really does underline it's
not a sort of decompress for
hard-working people it has got a party
tenor to it and from what you described
by the scene alleged in the garden it
does it does feel that way um
you know
is this something that brings down a
prime minister it has it got a
justification to it should they have
explained these allegations better you
know will it all be answered by the
inquiry which is is underway when will
we get
that information i mean there are so
many questions here pippa and so many
implications i guess
there's lots of questions i think um
first and foremost people be interested
to see what happens to martin reynolds
tonight whether he's still in post uh by
this bike by tomorrow morning i think it
makes it incredibly difficult for the
email trail um for him for him to remain
um but uh sue gray who's the white hole
enforcer who's now looking at all these
different allegations almost certainly
now i'm told tonight we'll be talking to
the prime minister directly who is uh
said to have been at a number of uh of
the events that she's looking into and
if he is found either by her um or
indeed if the police decide that he's
breached uh current advice regulations
then that puts him in very difficult
difficult
territory because throughout the number
10 strategy seems to have been to double
down to try and deny or indeed obfuscate
um and you know so often is the case in
these things it's often the cover-up
that gets you but um they created this
sort of web of confusion which uh she's
trying to sort of you know to cut
through and if the ultimate findings are
that the prime minister is in the wrong
then that puts him in a difficult
position with the public that's not to
say he's automatically going to go you
know this is midterm he has lots of woes
but there's a long way to general
election but anything which starts
piling up emails in the inboxes of his
already febrile tory back benches is not
good news for him given all the
speculation that's been going around in
recent weeks about about his own status
as tory leader
the guardian fury as email reveals
number 10 bring your own booze party
fury from families of the bereaved from
the backbenchers and from the other
political parties angela rainer telling
sky news tonight it was disgusting and
despicable
in blackford 2 who i spoke to calling
for both the resignation of martin
reynolds
and obviously the prime minister too i
think he's probably done that before on
this um but where do you see this uh
where do you see this heading harry and
and how genuinely serious is this for
the prime minister i think
the problem with this one is
this is really early on
in the pandemic um
this was the you know the height of
lockdown one when things were incredibly
strict when millions of people myself
included were you know locked up in a in
a small flat and taking the rules
incredibly seriously
um this was a you know a week before a
few days before the infamous sort of
dominic cummings barnard castle trip
um
and i think the what's really telling
for me and tonight and the
is the there were other emails around
flying around the building at that time
with people going
hang on are you sure this is a good idea
are you sure you know why are we
encouraging people to do this now i
suspect there will be a defense made by
the prime minister and his aides to sue
grey that this is a unique building that
all these people were working together
it wasn't meeting in public because they
were in a workspace
yet they might get off on us on their
technicality but in terms of you know
normal voters normal is the public and
the spirit of the rules i think this is
the
you could you could imagine anyone
making yeah i looked it up actually and
people would know better than many of us
because the mirror was among those who
uh revealed the dominic hummings thing
this the allegation of this is may the
20th i think the uh the dominic cummings
thing broke on the 22nd of may so just
two days later he's suggesting he was
one of those who's just it was a bad
idea as he uh helped to reveal the
allegations of this if if it had been
the other way around and this had been a
suggestion of a party after this broke
they might have cancelled it i think
don't you
possibly but it does shed a new light on
some of the sort of stonewalling and
obfuscation that we got from number 10
when we first started talking to people
there about the dominic cummings story
and i think it also
raises questions about um you know just
how firmly the prime minister stuck by
him at that time as you'll know 40 or 50
tory mps were calling for him to go but
they circled the wagons around dominick
cummings and the series of senior
cabinet ministers went out and defended
him over the rule breach for driving all
that all that way to durham when um you
know when the rest of the country was in
lochtime um and you know the prime
minister took a political gamble and
basically put his credibility on the
line to support cummings it makes you
wonder why he was doing that was it just
because as we thought at the time he has
a tendency to double down and support
those are closest to him or is it the
fact that a couple of days earlier
dominic cummings had warned the prime
minister that he shouldn't have this
this bash in the garden of number 10. i
mean let's hope that sue gray asks some
of these questions and do we know when
when that inquiry will report just as a
point of order as an interesting
journalist
i feel quite sorry for sue grey because
just every time it appears she's about
to
draw her big ring binder of
investigation clothes and hand it over
to the cabinet office another allegation
drop so she's opening her has to
interview more and more people i just
suspect we're probably still now a
couple of weeks away uh from seeing that
on dom coming so you know let's not
forget you know he may be
maybe throwing rocks now but it's
remarkable in his uh sort of four
thousand five thousand word defense uh
of his own actions last week that he
published on friday that miraculously
any party where he's
necking red wine or eating cheese or one
of his key lieutenants or allies is at
the center of the frame suddenly they're
not parties they're just work meetings
or that wasn't a party leave my friends
alone but um look over there look over
there at the prime minister so i'm not
sure anyone comes out of this
particularly well yes the the wrath of
those who feel wronged i guess um the
sun i don't know if i should speak to
you harry about it dr pippa don't be a
novak get boosted go on then tell us
about this one well scary scary results
that have been ticking in the last
couple of days is actually the number of
boosters has dropped off through the
floor whereas before christmas we were
doing a million nearly a million
boosters across the uk today uh on
monday they only did 140 000 which is
worrying people because
if you think about pfizer for example
that is a a batch of uh that is a
vaccine that once a batch of it is
opened it has to be thrown away at the
end of the day but not enough people are
coming forward and there's worry that
the uh the sort of the take-up rate only
two-thirds of eligible adults have been
boosted the take-up weight rate is
starting to wane and don't forget we had
all those big promises before christmas
about jabbing everyone uh eligible by
the new year it's clearly not uh it's
not happening and this with um a whole
host of potential policies that are that
are mooted talked about or on the table
the five days of isolation uh prime
minister pippa confirming they were
looking at today you know the rumors
about lateral flow tests whether they'd
become monetized or whatever lots um
lots in the offing really
yes but
if you look at the front page of the
yorkshire post today i think that's
really interesting tomorrow that's
really interesting because um they're
reporting that covered 19 rates in
yorkshire and humber are overtaking
those at the peak in london and you'll
remember that all the all the sort of uh
concern that was prompted by um the
london peak about whether restrictions
would have to be brought in and what the
impact would be
on um you know ambulance services and
services and the sort of service sort of
provision that hospitals could provide
um and you know that now that the
infections in london thankfully are
falling and i think faster than a lot of
scientists had predicted um obviously a
lot of people in hospital but it's you
know this sort of grounds of cautious
optimism yet um attention is now turning
to the rest of the country and you know
there are different parts of the country
which uh wouldn't necessarily have the
same uh
resilience if you like um as london with
its multiple um and massive hospitals uh
the new yorkshire post reporting how the
yorkshire ambulance service has had to
cut some of its non-emergency passenger
transport there's some concerns about
about operations and whether they're
going to be able to to go ahead um so
you know i think i think all eyes no
turn on the rest of the country to see
how they withstand omicron obviously the
hope is that they would stand it as well
as the southeast but um but we're no by
no means there yet so to talk of lifting
restriction
restrictions which are still in place
and and you know reducing self-isolation
periods um and cutting natural flows
number 10 is very clear um now is not
the time to do that when there's still
concerns over omicron we'll have to wait
a wee bit longer to see those um harry
back to your paper too what to do about
energy bills um what's the latest from
the government
well it sounds like uh richie sueneck
and boris johnson had quite an important
dinner on sunday night where they've
decided actually
despite resisting a cut to vat
on energy bills actually they're now
looking quite quite clearly at doing
that now that itself uh one source says
won't touch the sides of what's coming
down the track
for um for energy energy customers a
hike of two thousand pounds only five
percent of that is v80 so perhaps in
conjunction with perhaps a suspension of
green levees which could save 150 quid
overnight on bills and some more
targeted help for poorer households it
does seem that the message has got
through loud and clear actually it's a
long way to april and um
it feels like the government are finally
gearing up to uh some big retail offers
which uh as a son we will we would
welcome yeah and that's the government's
view what's the the view of one
electricity company which the ft has on
its front page pipa
yes it's pretty astonishing story really
is ovo the energy firm it's um it's
offshoot sse energy is sent an email to
customers giving them 10 tips to stay
warm and help cut on cut their their
energy bills this winter and they
include things like hugging your pet or
your partner and doing star jump uh
eating or eating a warm bowl of porridge
you know some of that might be common
sense of advice if you're working from
home and it's a bit chilly you get told
to get up in your desk but if you're
aiming at specifically people that are
struggling to pay these massive energy
bills then it really seems very
insensitive and the supply has been
called out by mps tonight i mean it's
really it's really very tenured yeah
eating ginger as well which is not a
cheap thing to buy on its own is it
anyway